l'inde lait est une oeuvre ses ailes au
québec jour 2 de la campagne électorale
le hors-champ commence dans ce studio à
rdi matin pendant la chronique sport une
invités s'installent au menu de
l'entrevue notamment les pogos on a une
grosse celui qui n'était pas tout à fait
des gelées apparemment c'est un nouvel
employé du parti
un tweet était en effet une erreur d'un
de nos gestionnaires de communauté est
l'erreur c'était d'écrire hier que
l'anglais est une langue officielle au
québec sauf que manon massé s'est fait
poser la question l'ade l'est et olemps
fcl au québec le tir sera presque
aussitôt rectifié
j'ai peut-être entretenu une certaine
confusion teintes aux méthodes québec qu
une langue officielle
mais pour le parti québécois c'est du
pain bénit sauf que le chef n'était pas
au courant de l'erreur oui elle a dit ça
une chochotte véronique hivon première
du genre pour que je ne manque pas et
l'attaché de presse qui est hors champ
va comprendre le message j'étais mal
briefé ce matin à l'âge de 10 ans
une heure plus légères ce matin au parc
philippe couillard est un peu jaloux
oh quand même 10 les jeunes école de
nice avec l'avant et deux heures trente
plus tard à bout d'une petite gette eu
le droit à une patrie
si mathieu propre radio canada montréal